pogo fight ram page what the hell
who are you all right press space button
well
i'm terribly sorry about that i seem to
be doing this the wrong way
something tells me i should be stabbing
up the butt but that doesn't seem to be
an option here
excuse me santa your large carcass is
getting in the way of this murder here
okey dokey then i don't know why that
was necessary
hi bro um you know as a brother myself i
don't want to kill you
cause i don't want to imagine killing my
brother
all right anyway
oh geez oh well moving on don't mind me
is it
what the hell where'd you come from all
right goodbye clones of my brother
it's not the same it's not the same
it's not the same oh hi
what the [ __ ] was that
okay all righty then
we're gonna pretend that was normal
mortal kombat
oh oh hi
how's it going there scorpio hey biscuit
excuse me i gotta get by with actual
important business to do thank god that
wasn't spikes because i thought i was
gonna die
oh oh i see your game
oh [ __ ] oh god oh
i have a transparent pelvis apparently
hello
okay goodbye then please eat my taint as
i move along
[Music]
hey hi hermac oh he
fell in fear or love not sure which
kabuski that's what you get that's
what's called a fatality
[ __ ] you stop the
i don't feel like we need to kill
everybody that wants to be naked i feel
like that's you know someone's
if people want to be naked that's their
proclivity okay
ow i'm broken f please stop
what i just got here i'm broken
don't make fun of me uh i don't know
i hey whoa hey back off old man i'm not
into defeat all right you go
okay good-bye i guess i didn't have to
kill you
my natural instinct was to kill you but
i don't know why i
wanted that mini golf what the [ __ ]
this isn't exactly mini golf but i'll
take it
all right whoo i feel accomplished
everything's going good in my life
alrighty then oh now this one's called
ultimate golf
dep wow okay that's legitimately golf
the other one was a [ __ ] version of
mini golf this is 100
legitimately golf okay ready
how do i do i i click
oh my god it is golf
it really is golf it's freaking golf
hey it's why did that not go
it's as frustrating as golf hit you son
of a tit
okay oh
eat ten dicks hey
wow okay eight bit men ooh insert coin
hell yeah oh hi who the
[ __ ] are you ah i'm sorry
oh geez i didn't expect it to do that
horrible of a death for you oh god i'm
not gonna be able to get this
ah fudge or knotters okay here gotta
build up the proper [ __ ] all right gonna
insert the coin
well i can't do that right i'm a dick
all right
gotta insert the coin there we go all
right
sorry mario
[Laughter]
oh it's just as horrible
okay good why do i want the other ones
this is really cool by the way two
deaths
two two deaths yay i don't get the death
well not yet i don't yeah oh [ __ ] oh
slotted in between the [ __ ]
titties yep oh okay
well hi oh dicaroni
well [ __ ] of balls i did nothing
correctly
all right mario you sack of [ __ ] let's
try this again hey
eat a dick now i have no remorse just a
few seconds ago
i had nothing but ugh
he had a wife yay i'm murdered
whoa okay all right not in the death
yeah not in the death
yeah well that's in the same hole i did
before
not in the death not in the
patisski oh jesus not
in the death yeah [ __ ]
okay thank you here [ __ ] oh god
wow oh oh
i'm already dangling by my intestines
which is an amazing factor i don't know
how that happened
chabooski this time actually winning
a [ __ ] god damn
it no
actually winning all right i'll take it
teary schmurden
okay i'll take it cured schmurden all
right mario
good thing i know how to play this okay
decapitated
as all should be spirigan [ __ ]
[ __ ] hold it harder than i thought [ __ ]
this is harder than a slam dunk
schrebensky
well missed you on purpose chabooski
well
all right just enough oh don't you b
dick
oh you be dick you be dick chaboosky
chaboosky yeah okay
okay not where i ah yes
why oh no why oh no ho
oh ow i just
got here oh screw you
you [ __ ] slam the coin
roll [ __ ] throw [ __ ] throw the ball
[ __ ] god damn it [ __ ]
slam it [ __ ]
oh got him triple kill on one win
no eat
ten dicks [ __ ] you
this is [ __ ] impossible oh god
why oh god i know
oh god i know it's got to get it up
why not enough momentum that's [ __ ]
why
slam it no
oh okay i did it so i gotta
not break my goddamn legs oh
[ __ ] why no get away oh [ __ ] you man
oh it's [ __ ] [ __ ] god damn it
[ __ ] you super jet pack oh
jesus oh
hi oh oh god
[Music]
who died also there there's a lot more
body parts than was just me
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching
if you want to see more happy wheels
right now check the description or click
the annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist
and if you want to see more happy wheels
in the future please click the like
button to let me know
thanks again everyone and as always i
will see
you in the next video bye-bye